Aaron Sampson here with our top five
tips for battlefield hardlines Hotwire
mode number one put an RPG and a stinger
up in your trunk the weapon that
destroys vehicles most effectively is
still the old RPG the weapon that shoots
sound choppers the best is still you
guessed it the old stinger depending on
the round put one in the sedan one in
the coupe and you're covered also when
you fire
don't waste time getting out of the car
or getting up on the roof just switch to
the passenger seat
fire drive away number two be a clutch
driver a lot of people think they know
how to drive in Hotwire mode but they
don't driving doesn't just mean going
fast depending on how the rounds
progressing you've got a number of jobs
pay attention to new Hotwire cars when
they pop up it's your job to ferry
players to them are you solo well then
avoid everybody is your car full and
your team's winning hell yeah go hunting
don't forget that sedans and coupes can
also equip reinforced chassis or
maintenance and smoke or extinguisher to
help you survive some pretty big hits
also if you ever get stuck spam melee to
bash your car off objects number three
be the designated destroyer if driving
cars isn't your thing there's a huge
role for you to play in Hotwire if you
want to be a mobile medical ammo
dispenser simply stick your deployable
of choice to high profile vehicles
assuming this doesn't get patched out
mechanic playing the satellite phone
near car so your team can get to them
quickly
also sabotage cars and mark cars with
tracers so anyone with an RPG including
yourself can destroy them from anywhere
else on the map professional use your
laser tripmines in high-traffic areas to
let friendly cars pass and demolish
enemy cars that are chasing use your
sniper rifles to harass and shoot down
choppers and enforcer one-word c4 use it
to drive cars away from your side of the
map that brings us to number four use
high-capacity magazines weapons like the
mechanic's p90 have a lot around
standard but a must accessory for any
weapon is
magazine the thinking is pretty
straightforward cars go by fast and you
have a limited period of time to get the
driver or passengers before they break
line of sight the enforcers battle
rifles can be your friend
due to high damage output but only if
you make enough kills to purchase
compensators and grips to counter for
that savage recoil similarly both
professional classes have bolt-action
rifles that can chamber the 3 3/8 Magnum
round an accessory that does more damage
to vehicles and finally number 5 learn
your Maps Everglades only has a few
deepwater areas but almost all rivers
are drivable make them your roads
derailed has a storm drain that's great
for doing laps and making money
similarly Riptide has a sandbar that you
can circle for a while making points
before enemies figure out what you're
doing income after you using the stunt
driver gadget and map knowledge you can
get away from car hunters or get to
capture cars faster than most everybody
else well that's it for our top five
tips for Hotwire mode follow these bits
of advice and make more money than
you'll know what to do with thanks for
watching and for more coverage of
battlefield hardline stay tuned to game
spot com